and you know we talked about uh picking  your poison uh we love that i love the  tiny tacos but maybe not the sliders but  what i really love are bagels from our  friend red hot at the new york stock  exchange hint hint  john heather  hand tent wing sweet nudge  cell carriers delaying activating 5g  networks around some airports including  here and you can now order those covid  test kits from the government and  they're free dianne king hall knows all  about red hot she's joining us live from  new york this morning with those stories  i know the bagel story i know i know  good morning i know i bring you a a  story of some bees bears but not bagels  what's that john heather so this is what  happened on wall street yesterday the  bears mauled wall street unfortunately  so it's not a good day to look at your  401k hold off on that remember you're in  it for the long haul